happily-ever-after only exists in fairy
tales yet a talking teddy bear is about
to marry his girlfriend I now pronounce
you teddy bear and wife may kiss the
bear proving that Americans don't give a
crap about anything so I got some big
nose
Tammy win and I are gonna have a baby
awesome wait how do you guys yeah we
need a sperm donor where's that what are
you doing getting ready to it are you
getting ready what do you teach it what
are you doing your hand I'm doing this
for you it's when I get in that can just
bust it up what do you think you're a
Red Lobster buddy catch what somebody's
kids I'm gonna take a picture I posted
on Facebook what hashtag or Monday we
have a baby you're gonna have to prove
you're a person in a court of law
this is a nightmare we got a fight we'll
get a lawyer and we'll sue the
government these civil rights I'm
Samantha Jackson must be Ted yeah
Samantha Jackson what's your middle name
Leslie oh my god yes Sam L Jackson
that's great um II just like Sam L
Jackson who is that never seen any movie
ever he's the black guy can I do the
same rights as everybody else just
because you're different can you get me
my life back
do you believe you have a salt what did
you think I would do at this moment
objection overruled
in the eyes of the law the important
thing about being German is making a
contribution to society we de Hills my
coffee you're not building rockets
figure it out the prick 20 bucks I got
toss a Cookie Crisp into that guy's ass
crack do it I'm gonna do it sir I
apologize for my five-year-old child bad
boy you sit there and eat your fish
nuggets
all right I'm gonna ask you to test
questions are you ready yep bring it on
do you consider yourself to be human
objection sustained no the witness can
overrule hi Bob guilty ocular say hey
let's briefcase forgot in my chamber
stop beaver on the witness arrest let's
get totally be lawyers thank you